العش هو المكان الذي يكون لديك فيه
إحساس بالحماية والقوة ، إنه مثل
معبد أرضي أو معبد طبيعي ،
يتبع الخشب نمطًا ولكن ليس
فرعًا واحدًا هو نفسه باني العش الذي
أتبع هذه الأنماط ومعظم
تم تدريب العمل لإخراج أفضل
هذه الأشكال مع بعضها البعض
[موسيقى]
أنا معجب بجيسون وأنا منشئ العش لقد
بدأت في بناء أعشاش عندما كنت طفلاً ،
كان بناء العش حقًا عملية بديهية
لمجرد جمع الفروع
وبناء  نمت الحصون في الأصل
وأصبح العش أكبر وأكثر تفصيلاً
الآن ، بعض الأعشاش كبيرة مثل
مائة ألف رطل من الخشب ،
أصعب جزء في بناء العش هو
بالفعل جمع كل الخشب الذي
أستخدمه بالمنشار لقطع الخشب الذي أستخدمه
منجل لقطع جميع الأوراق الزائدة
ومن هناك أقدر حقًا أنك تعرف
نوع الأشكال التي أمتلكها ، وما نوع
المواد التي يجب أن أعملها مع
عملية بناء العش أولاً ،
وهي إنشاء الأساس
والبنية التحتية  ثم أتبع تلك
الأشكال النحتية الأكبر التي قمت بربطها
معًا بمواد أصغر
يمكنني نسجها داخل وحول
الشجرة ، وأستخدم كل جزء من الشجرة جذع الشجرة
وصولاً إلى أصغر غصين
وفرع من الشجرة.  لقد وصلت إلى
حيث اعتدت على بنائها على
مقطورات مسطحة وتحريكها
، وفي كثير من الحالات ، أقوم بنقلها
عبر البلاد لأن الأعشاش
ثقيلة جدًا إذا استخدمت الرافعات والرافعات
الشوكية بأنواع مختلفة من المعدات ،
فهذا كله عبارة عن شجرة الكينا  هناك أكثر من 75
نوعًا مختلفًا من الأوكالبتوس في هذا
العقار ، لقد قمت ببناء حوالي 50 عشًا في جميع
أنحاء البلاد ، والآن أقوم بشكل أساسي
ببناء أعشاش مع الأطفال ضمن
بيئة
تعليمية كمعلم ، حيث إنه من
المهم حقًا العمل مع الأطفال
ومساعدتهم على إدراك أنهم  لدي القدرة
على تشكيل بيئة وخلقها ،
سأوضح لك كيف يمكننا دمج
تلك الفروع في دوامة أحب
إخراج الأطفال إلى الطبيعة والتفاعل
مع الطبيعة و  والعش هو في
الواقع تعاون مع الطبيعة
أعلم أنني قمت بعمل جيد عندما
يبدو أن العش هو شيء كان من الممكن
تقريبًا أن ينمو من الأرض
[موسيقى]
أنت